do you think it's possible to fall in
love with the robot yeah I mean people
fall in love with things all the time
well people have fallen in love with
Yoshi robots probably
I guarantee you there's people listening
to this that are a little bit
heartbroken saying that you've never
fall in love with your shady robots
they're like but I had a relationship
like I had an emotional connection to
that robot like the one with it with a
parent Patsy on the back oh that one
that one I do like I like that one a lot
um that's probably my favorite like
shitty robot can you explain it so it's
the machine it was my friend Daniel
Beauchamp and I we had this long-running
joke about a proud parent machine that
you could give a quarter and a pass you
on the shoulder says proud of you yeah
um so yeah I still have that hanging on
my wall in my workshop so that one I'm
I'm really happy with I just think it's
a really
funny concept and also I executed the
build well so that was so it's an arm
like what's the build yeah I built it
off of an old lamp arm yeah basically
it's just a motorized arm and this kind
of torso
of of a person so it's actually a hand
right
correctly it's like a laser cut it's
just laser cut plywood and it kind of
has like it looks creepy yeah which I
like yeah the creepy helps with the yeah
and yeah it's as proud of you son
because I just thought that sounded more
funny than proud of you daughter and
also proud of you son just
it immediately communicates that it's
apparent it's not just like a collie or
something it's like proud of you
yeah oh my charges you a quarter for it
yeah but he added like chat GPT on top
of that and uh fine tune it on
conversations you've had with your
parents and all of a sudden you have a
thing that can fundamentally transform
your psyche yeah
that's all it takes that's a beautiful
creation how did you come up with that
creation I was my friend Daniel and I
who had a long-running joke about it